are some of the bigger challenges with
creating this device feedback it is
smaller
um so
the the most difficult challenge was
really thinking about the products
weight so we have thousands of focus
groups and you know in different
orientation with handheld there was a
there was a notation that when people
were playing games lying on the bed and
when you drop it hit their nose it's
really good so uh when we thought about
it it has to be the the weights and why
we wanted to develop that performance we
have to give it a system we need to have
better cooling but at the same time we
have to reduce weight so that was the
most difficult part and we figured up on
the focus group that the optimized
weight was actually 600 Grand so we
actually say 600 grams as our goal but
we went through Relentless efforts of
reducing the weight room was still
agreeing to him but we were pretty we're
pretty proud about what we were
still that's the best
design
apparel all the other designs that
you've seen in the market the other
thing is
um the the software side of things being
able to assist customers to navigate
through different experiences between
um a controller type of setup a keyboard
mouse type of setup as well as a
touchscreen setup so we ended up running
to ECS these these are controllers that
are able to convert informations about
your keyboard mouse included as well as
your controller inputs and we have two
two of them running in parallel so it's
easier for customers and we create both
for Ultra mode so if you don't know
which profile to use it will actually
help you to choose and you know those
two are the most difficult part that we
have to learn
okay I think one of the other big
questions people have is many of these
devices are Linux or Android
what was the main factor why did you
guys pursue windows with this device
so first of all Android we have an
Android gaming device which is the iot
Chrome 7
with Android games where you have the
theology phone that the service that
markets
um but like I said I'm giving myself I I
don't want to go and repurchase my games
I'm on the platform that actually is
inclusive with all the libraries that
they have I have access to I don't want
to be limited right so that's that's
what Windows give you such inclusive
environments that you can do all that
the other thing is
they actually offer you the excess of
the latest Hardware because of the
install based on Windows the most of the
latest Hardware will always have the
latest driver and firmware for it so you
can always ensure that you get the best
technology at the time
well I've actually had the privilege to
use this device a lot with Windows 11
and I gotta say it just performs
beautifully I mean what makes this the
ideal device for Windows and what kind
of improvements can we expect to see in
the future
yeah well am I on yeah okay hi everybody
um so I have kind of grown up a little
bit uh in the windows ecosystem actually
at Microsoft
am I on not on
yeah
can everybody hear me
so hey everybody uh my name is Rowan
I've grown up within uh Microsoft
managing and working in this ecosystem
I mean I think Sean has said it really
well you know one of the things that I
think we can always rely on these kind
of the power of the PC gaming community
and you know for me there's a couple
things I think I know it's just great
like versus familiar you know when you
pick up this device you never kind of
know how to use it like you know how to
connect devices to it you know how to
navigate the user experience on it so
there's this familiarity of that that I
think is really important
I think Innovation is is super important
to this as well and constantly making
sure that the platform's keeping up with
the power of where the ecosystem is
going I think we see that we see the
Silicon optimizations that we'll talk
um you even see that with us taking
them at an Xbox
is a really a great example of that
um and then and then for me there's this
aspect of compatibility you know
really the device and platform is kind
of in service of the games that you're
going to play and you know I'm proud
that you can pick this up and you can
see the the app experience and it's got
all the stores in there that you if
you're not locked into just an Xbox
store that's that's a really important
value position from my perspective kind
of putting
equipment and putting the game
experience
I think a big part of that value
proposition is
yeah and how do you think that they use
the most out of this yeah
[Music]
um so you know like obviously I want I
want Xbox game pass to do something that
is super valuable to the players
experiences and so we're going to put a
lot of energy into making that really an
exceptional a really conceptual
experience and so you know Game Pass uh
is essentially something that you gotta
if you have a monthly membership to you
get three months free on the online
device and it basically exposes you to
um that you can kind of somewhat play at
a fingertips uh we have day and day so
the day we launch it the day it shows up
in the impacts for all of our Xbox game
studios you see that today with
Minecraft uh margining
um you know we've done Partnerships
across the ecosystem as well
um so I I'm excited that you actually
you know have your EA membership in
there
that's all right facilities that you can
integrate in for membership for members
of Xbox so to me you know this this is
very much kind of really trying to put
games somewhat front and center and make
that really accessible to players I kind
of like this idea of power to play and
how quickly you can do that
um and there's an aspect I think we've
seen with Game Pass and people really
trying it and using it to kind of try
out new games play them and decide which
ones you want to download there's a more
creative and curiosity aspect I think
when you have a whole catalog of things
I agree all right Ronaldo I mean I think
one thing a lot of people are excited
about with this device is the fact that
this is again held with rdma3 how did we
get such a big performance lead from
last generation of this generation
yeah so I think when thinking about a
device like this the the original
thought process was how do you deliver
performance and efficiency it has it has
to be both you can't deliver performance
for the same performance and you can't
deliver efficiency for the sake of
efficiency it has to to find that white
balance so what we originally thought of
what what architecture did we put into
this uh this chip RDA 3 just made sense
uh our gaining three is one and a half
times more performance per watt so it
really drove that performance that you
needed but at the right level of
efficiency and I've played around with
it we've we've tested it out we've seen
on most of the the demanding AAA titles
we're hitting 60 FPS and above so it's
going to be a fantastic gaming
experience very performant very
efficient so I've got the CPU sign
what's new with the Phoenix architecture
Virginia yeah so a very similar concept
we decided Well what what is the
architecture on the Poor Side that we
have to put in to deliver the best
performance but at the same uh the same
time the best efficiency so we went with
our Zen four architecture
um our Zen architecture uh not only does
it power our high-end desktops and our
you know thin and light gaming Solutions
but it's going to be powering our C1
series
um we had more cash on more cash so it
reduces the latency and then on top of
that we're kind of pairing our software
to drive a lot of our efficiency uh
performance performance at an efficiency
level so but in the end it's really not
about the individual pieces it's how do
you Stitch it all together so it's the
zenfor architecture it is the rdna3
architecture it's our software that
wraps everything around you it's
partnering with you know someone like
Jesus that can take and harness all of
that efficiency and power creating a
device that is thin light mobile that
delivers what the user wants at the at
the uh the weight the portability
I mean how much engineering had to go
into actually making a device that I can
achieve good performance particular
games at that 30 Watts a lot a lot um
this wasn't this wasn't something that
we just woke up one day and said hey
let's go create a thin and light gaming
solution or portable you know handheld
PC it's been 10 years in the making for
AMD we we entered the Apu Market 10
years ago
um we know performance we know how to
deliver high performance CPUs
Edge peas we know efficiency we when you
look at our consumer size of business we
deliver the most efficient laptops in
the market with the best battery life
the best portability
when we got into the gaming markets The
Notebook gaming Market
um we kind of joke around and said
inside of it he said we want to put
mobile back in Mobile gaming
you know five six seven years ago the
the definition of a laptop a gaming
laptop was a 28 30 35 millimeter thick
desktop replacements and it was great
because you got the performance but
there was really nothing mobile about it
except that you could put it in maybe a
you know I want to look at rats and
carts and lugging around with you
because it was so heavy and not very
portable so we set out on a mission to
drive Mobility back into gaming several
years back and you know was it four
years ago through that we introduced the
G14 was kind of that first attempt to
say how do we drive thin and light
gaming
um the G14 has been an awesome platform
but it really kind of revolutionized the
industry is to rethink how we think
about mobile gaming you don't have to
have a big desktop replacement to drive
the same level of performance that
you're used to in gaming and then this
is just an evolution of that
um over the years we've always said how
do we drive more Mobility how do we
drive more efficiency how do we get the
performance in the right form factors
and so this is really a culmination of
10 years of the works of a lot of
engineering efforts to drive the most
efficient the most performance of
CPU and GPU into a handheld gaming
device
I think I think I'll agree that the Ally
is returning
what is
um where do you see not only windows but
Xbox going from here now that we've had
this new product in the market yeah you
know I I think it's interesting to think
about who the customer for this is and I
think there's going to be a lot of
appeal to existing PC players who can
now have this experience that they can
sort of Take On The Go
um but I also think it's going to be
interesting to see how it actually
appeals to an imposter
costume that's both you know like a
console player who hasn't necessarily
been like myself
um now I actually have a way with the
Game Pass apps and the experiences like
I actually have a way to now go both
experience Cloud streaming of my console
apps but also
also experience with PC PC games and so
this idea that I can now have a form
factor that I can bring with me on the
go like you talk about logging a laptop
like how many people have with their
monitor in their console in the back of
the car you know like I'm pretty sure
lots of folks in the rooms have done
that right so this idea now that
I can do this my favorite thing is like
with my hand it's like can I play it in
the back of the back CR like I like it
just completely changes the narrative in
my household on um so I'm I'm pretty
excited about kind of
and I'm excited about it as this
ultimate accessory and and experience
that that whole complement
ing but also
because I think that's a pretty unique
thing that the Ally is doing a couple
with
it yeah I mean just a few years ago
[Music]
I want to talk a little bit more about
the Z1 series
what exactly like
yeah so
we always start off with the end
consumer in mind
um we wanted to go look at what is that
market segment Unity
um I think it can be confusing if you
end up creating a one-size-fits all
because in the end you don't really get
the best of both worlds you kind of get
the worst of all worlds if you try to
create a high performance CPU but it's
not very efficient or vice versa so
we've we this year with our 7000 series
have really looked at how do we attack
the segments and provide the best
experience for the End customer for that
segment whether it's our 7045 HX series
processor that is geared towards the the
high-end Enthusiast Global gamer whether
it's our 7040 HS series which is thin
and light gaming that provides kind of
that best balance of a thin portable
gaming laptop that does it all whether
it's gaming or you use it as your
everyday device and then we said we
should go create a unique optimized
solution that is for this handheld
gaming because they're different
experiences they're different
optimization point so we have to go go
after so we created the Z1 series that
will be servicing this market and again
it's all about the optimization reports
the balance between performance and
efficiency that's very different in this
system versus a high-end you know 70 45
HX that all they want is the the maximum
throughput so that was kind of the
Genesis how do we make sure that we are
targeting the consumer need for the
market and we're creating the
development
thank you Siri
glad that wasn't me
yeah so that was trying to create the Z1
series really targeted tour thank you
for distracting me Serena lost my train
of thought
um really really at the end consumer
space and not confusing the market of
website fits all but it's the perfect
size for the perfect Market
so Frank do you do you think we're going
to see
long-term use for these kind of case
AP I do like Ronaldo said
um this isn't something that just
emerged as an idea a year or two ago
this has been something that's been in
the works at AMD or over a decade but a
lot of people don't realize is AMD
processors power some of the most
powerful gaming devices today like the
Xbox the PlayStation I think even
his power by our processors today and
what that's enabled us to do for the
last decade is empowering these types of
devices is getting really really good at
powering some of the greatest gaming
device that are out there
out there games are optimized on our
architecture our architecture is being
the Zen architecture and the rdna
architecture those very same
architectures are in these devices today
so there are there will be hundreds and
maybe thousands of games that have been
designed to run efficiently on our
technology for a decade now that all
translates over to the Ally all those
benefits and it's also going to
translate over into giving you and I
grow and set compatibility with all of
these games so if you bought a game five
years ago six years ago on steam or the
Epic store or any of these platforms or
Microsoft store you're going to be able
to play these games on this device there
are very few other gaming devices that
give you that type of a value
proposition that's one of the things
that makes PC
special and because this is a
platform you're getting all of those
benefits if you buy a game today you
know in five years you'll be able to
play that on the Ally version 5.
um and so that that assurance that
you're an investment and that these
franchises and these characters and
these stories and these narratives that
you just fall in love with you're going
to be able to carry them with you
literally for generations to come I
think is what makes this device just
really special and something that you
you know that you can invest in and it's
going to grow with you over time
what other kind of Technologies in our
ability to this device that users can
take advantage of well what's really
interesting is obviously there are other
gaming Hangouts that are out there
um but what's really unique about this
one is in the leading gaming handheld
that's out there that sells tens of
millions of units a year has
approximately 1 20th the amount of
performance that the LI has one twenty
of the amount of performance
the wireless technology that Trump's
talking about is state of the art latest
Wireless Technologies out there your
performance is going to be exceptional
if you want to download the games and
play them back on the device you have
the option to be able to do that you're
going to download them at incredibly
fast speed they're going to load because
they have a very high performance
storage device that's in there they're
going to load quickly they're going to
place
all that performance but if you don't
want to download the game locally you
can play it in the cloud as well so you
have the flexibility of it being a cloud
gaming handheld or being a local
playback gaming handheld it really is
like everything that every handheld
device out there has tried to do but
they've only done it like you know
they've done three things really well or
four things really well but you've
always had the compromise or sacrifice
this that or the other you can't play
Gold
you can only play cloudy
with me play Cloud games you can only
play local games
the Ally has solved all
of them you do anything and everything
when Sean talks about all this truly
isn't All in One gaming device so you
can use it as a gaming handheld but your
entire library of logo or cloud-based
games you can use it as even a desktop
replacement as you go when you connect
it to the dock or you can connect it to
a TV and play with your friends no other
devices unable to do that for you sure
you can connect other devices to a TV
but can you actually use it as a
computer replacement as a laptop or a
desktop replacement there's no other
device out there like that so this is
truly a revolution in what a form factor
like this can do and this will set the
stage for every other device that comes
after it much like gaming notebooks did
20 years ago
Sean one of the things moves on your
presentation was the command center and
the command center has a load of options
that we saw on there and I want to know
just kind of like some of the thought
process behind designing that utility
yeah we want it to be simple
um to say one of the examples like um
Envy is a great technological gradient
super resolution which allows you to run
them at a large machine but scale an app
to a higher resolution and deliver more
frames I personally myself taking
advantage of eyes out all the time but
you know without keyboard mouse this is
difficult it's not difficult it's a
different experience to a laptop where
you can launch a model window and then
you can go to the button right launch
this software and then choose that you
know that that process on this device
has to be easy and simple that's why we
just built those shortcuts those
shortcuts will allow you to have access
to the the optimization that you want to
apply as often as possible and that's
why the community center is correctly
so I think another thing that's unique
about the Allies the fact that it works
with an external gives you the XD
um what was some of the reasoning behind
wanting to make this compatible with the
extra mobile
so again we always make advice for
ourselves
XG mobile
started as when we think about external
Graphics I don't know if you guys will
call external Graphics used to be like a
mini desktops it would be bigger than
this laptop right here right you're
pretty much carrying a 700 watt power
brick as well as the um as well as the
external graphics with you that's not
portable that that's just now portable
so three years ago when we launched
audio Cloud we knew that the benefit of
Xtreme mobile is if you want to have a
gaming laptop and the performance is
needed when you need it you know you
don't have to feel a super clunky laptop
that's 25 30 millimeters you can have
them as thin as 70 millimeters like the
RG flow and then when you need the
external Graphics you can just talk it
out so we took a different approach on
XG Mobile today XG mobile is actually 90
smaller than an external desktop
graphics and on top of that you don't
have to carry any
built in to the XG mobile so that was
the picture three years ago but we
actually started thinking about rgli
five years ago so when you look at today
XG mobile was not it's not only
compatible with one LG plus series it's
compelled with all the algae flow series
The x13 x16 z13 and today LG Airline the
scenario is if you're in a student Dom
or you are in the family you know you if
you need a graphic power as a family you
only need one of them right you share it
and it boosts your performance right
there and in the future if you upgrade
you upgrade the XG mobile to the latest
Graphics it will be it's much cost
effective that way
okay back to talking about gaming
communities PC versus console that's
always been the thing we have the
console awards for years and years and
years and you know in recent years
that's really been something that's been
merging more and more how do you see a
device like the Ally bridging that Gap
even further yeah I mean it's um
again like I think it's fascinating
because it really is a device
in Paris your BC and is Standalone and
so to me like that is very unique I
don't see anything else in the market
that's like that
um but I think you have to pattern match
this with with game experiences and so
that's why I'm I'm pretty excited about
how kind of all in the AZ team has gone
on game masks um because I think people
don't know what they want to play until
they actually have a chance to play it
and then they're like oh my gosh
this is
um some of our game statistics when game
packs are pretty fascinating 30 of
people uh have played new genres that
they haven't played before they're
playing
recording games 90 of them have said
that they're playing a title that they
never would have played otherwise and so
to me there's a pretty strong
correlation between this subscription to
a whole threat the portfolio of games
that you wouldn't find individually to
hire engagement and if you look at
creators I mean yes you you know you
want to deliver these incredible
creative experiences but you do also
have a business to run and so I I think
the Allies can be pretty critical to
both
increasing sort of the share of time
that a Creator can now have because
they're going to be able to deliver
their experiences kind of outside of
minutes when previously there just
there's nothing there
um but I think you know you're also
being able to get a better share of
wallet as a as a part of some of those
extra because I two minutes
so I really do see that you know someone
has a pretty
package and so I'm I'm pretty Keen to
kind of see where where you know in
particular this handheld implementation
goes
yeah just kind of talking about the
publisher side of things I mean
Microsoft has built this huge platform
Publishers and developers do you see the
Ally being a new opportunity for you
know kind of expanding that yeah I do
and I mean I think I I think there's
this going to be this interesting
balance
um you know with with the Publishers on
it because now I I think they're gonna
see again like this opportunity both
economically and inexperienced I think
the other place that we've been spending
a fair amount of time with Publishers is
is kind of more on the experience layer
um because now I think you are going to
kind of pick up and where you left off
on the Ally and then you're going to put
it down and you're going to go back to
everyone Z and when that happens like
what is that experience and so did we
successfully save your state so that
when you go back to your PC you can
instantly resume where you left off
um have we invested with the Publishers
on crossplace that you can navigate
across different platforms whether
that's in Xbox cons
[Music]
so so that's kind of now the next layer
I would say that we're overlaying into
our conversations with Publishers
because we think
we think variance is is critical
um both to the community and also to you
know giving you know giving giving
players more options
you know one thing everyone loves to ask
is what's next this is kind of the
starting point you said this has been a
five-year journey to get to this point
where do you see this taking gaming with
Rog moving forward
it's a big question
so so
um I think gaming is one of the most
engaged entertainment
um and get me his education like to me I
learned history through Age of Empires
and by the way it's more productive than
textbook and then um I see my kids
create their own world in Minecraft and
no kids and
and gaming is is Art I mean you you have
hyper realistic Graphics these days they
kind of just transport you into a
parallel game Universe with all the Epic
stories so
the fundamental about gaming is the time
the gamers can enjoy with it
um we have components gaming components
that you know help people to build
giving their steps with gaming laptops
we have gaming phones today we have
um they mean handhelds
all to the whole we want Gamers to
really have easy access to the contents
to the fun to to play to enjoy and this
is this is how core value of Republic of
gamer is really improving that
experience having access to the contents
and have fun moving forward we hope that
you know with LG Li it will help
publisher to think about when I create
games what's the optimized experience
for a handheld device like that on the
on the PC game setup story where I can
think about okay that experience can be
different to your traditional PC gaming
as a publisher how do they think about
customers actually have fun with devices
like that and eventually they will
create new scenarios that then we can
continue to improve on so you know in
the future I just think that that works
cohesively together if I'm a publisher
and the house
all right well I think for the most part
A lot of the media questions that we've
decided ahead of time have been answered
but there are a few more here
um so the RNG Allied was designed with
the extreme Mobile in live but will it
also work with other desktop edpus such
as USB type-c or Thunderbolt
so this debate actually came in three
years ago so we actually thought about
having the desktop type of GPU with type
CEO from the books the the main reason
that we didn't go to the route is you're
kind of limited by the bandwidth you're
limited by the thumb program with um
compared to the graphic performance that
they can deliver uh
from the desktop Graphics so we ended up
delivering Xtreme mobile that has a
primary PCI indirect so you are not
limited by the bandwidth and it's way
smaller too so yes it is compatible you
can connect a uh any external desktop
Graphics into it it's just not going to
be delivered the same experience that
you're going to see on my extreme
okay another question we have was is
there an ally verified program similar
to valves that Asus will use how quickly
is this compatibility pipeline expected
to work
okay so um
with Windows usually don't meet the
bearings
yeah you don't you don't need that you
don't you don't need everybody
it is compatible everything plays on
Windows and plays on my own
easy peasy all right um obviously
everybody wants to ask about the
availability of the various models of an
ally in the US UK Australia markets can
you talk about any of that or anything
about pricing
I really hope I can give you the
information today that we are working
with retailers um
um making sure that the final
business terms and everything so give us
till May 11th to give you that full
picture of pricing availability and the
countries that they will launch this
product
sorry typical
um
thank you all for joining us here today
thank you guys for joining us here on
the panel we are going to be around so
feel free to hang out through
questions and we'll do our best to ask
to answer thank you thank you
[Applause]
foreign